Tom bilius sold his company Quest
Nutrition for a billion dollars in cash
and today we had the opportunity to fly
to Los Angeles and learn the secrets
from someone who successfully started
and sold one of the most recognizable
nutrition brands in the world to be
honest we both went into this having no
idea what to expect but within one hour
we were blown away with what we heard so
you'll be able to get an inside look
into what it's like to sell a billion
dollar company how you could start your
own business from the ground up and how
you could find the love of your life as
soon as you subscribe and hit the like
button if you haven't done that already
you done that Jack I have but before we
get into it we gotta thank our sponsor
streamyard upfront costs can be a huge
deterrent for people trying to get into
content creation and if you want to
start a podcast like us surprisingly you
don't need to build this super fancy
studio and that's because of our sponsor
stream yard stream yard's a powerful
live streaming production program that
allows you to broadcast live video to
social media channels like YouTube
Facebook and twitch with stream yard you
could easily create high quality live
streams with just a few clicks and their
intuitive interface makes it easy to get
started they allow you to create your
own custom backgrounds add multiple
cameras and also add on multiple guests
streamyard also has powerful analytic
tools that help you measure the success
of your live stream with stream yard you
can see how many people are watching
your live and also Which social media
platforms are driving the most viewers
plus they integrate with popular
streaming and analytics tools like
Google analytics and YouTube Creator
studio so try stream yard today using
the link Down Below in the description
to create professional looking live
streams in just minutes again the link
is down below in the description to get
started today and now let's get to the
podcast we got start where we're at this
house is uh very special to me because
it was sold by Jason oppenheim yes uh
when did you buy it was it two years ago
three three years ago that would have
been in 2019 very end of 2019. yeah so I
covered this house actually on my
channel when it was being built did you
really went through with the developer a
really nice guy and with Jason too and
uh going through this house the amount
of work that he put in US is insane is
telling Jack it's like removing some of
the telephone poles in front of the
house and like even fixing the roofs of
the people below you to make sure that
they're not ugly roofs those are things
that you don't think about when you're
buying like you know a few million
dollar house but when you get up to this
caliber of home and Jack said it's like
dude this is the nicest house this is
the nicest house I've ever been yeah
it's insane congratulations and you were
the buyer of this which I think is so
cool to come full circle and be back
here because I remember this garage and
the owner had an extensive car
collection and he had a lineup of cars
here and uh and he had a centenario
Lamborghini over here in the front that
was all carbon fiber and it's cool to
see that it's now a podcast yeah YouTube
Studio yeah how did you get your start
to be able to buy a house like this I'm
gonna I'm gonna go fast and then when
you find something you think your
audience will care about we can drill
down let's stop right there all right so
I did not grow up with money I used to
think I grew up poor I did not I have
since seen poverty but we were lower
middle class so I didn't know anybody
with money I didn't just didn't know how
to think like a person with money
nothing I went to film School graduated
thought I would get the three picture
deal I did not and I found myself
completely hopeless because I had no
idea how to break into the industry
which that is like if I had to guess
what the thing is that really makes me
resonate with people I can explain that
moment you have big dreams but you don't
know what to do like that's my sweet
spot and that was so it induced such
paralysis in my life that I know what
that's like to be stuck there and for me
it all happened pre-internet so I just
was like what do I do and so very long
story condensed way down I end up
writing a screenplay it gets made into a
feature film I was horrified by the
results but I had met these two very
successful entrepreneurs they said
you're coming to the world with your
handout if you want to control the art
you have to control the resources so
come with us and get rich what was the
film uh oh God it's called Brazen Bowl
uh
to give it give us those yeah thanks
Graham I did say there was nothing off
limits and here we go
so yeah no it's fine but uh it was about
so do you guys ever hear the kill Dozer
no all right this is a real thing so the
everything I'm about to say is a hundred
percent true okay there was a guy who
had like a machine shop and he uh had
the the people in the zoning committee
come and change the zoning of his
business and so he went out of business
and he was very angry that they changed
the zoning and so it takes him a year
but he builds what ended up being known
as the killdozer and he basically takes
a bulldozer soups it up puts armor
plating on it and then this guy remember
this is all real this guy then takes
that bulldozer and destroys the homes
and businesses of everyone on the
committee and but he does it surgically
so if your house is in between two other
houses he didn't touch either house on
either side just demolishes him now this
is terrible no one should ever do this
and you're in a very dark place if you
do but if you kind of like a Revenge
tale it was pretty gnarly okay but the
bad news is very negative punch line he
gets killed so he it's it's like his
last stand but ends up destroying all
the stuff and so I was like let's make
the villain of our story
that guy but you can't use the real
story obviously but that was the
inspiration and so Brazen Bulls about
this guy that gets done wrong by people
he blames them for everything and so he
lures them into a building that's empty
and we actually filmed it in LA in this
empty building and played by Michael
Madsen if you guys know who that is a
regular on the Quentin Tarantino circuit
and uh thought thought it was a really
cool idea just didn't execute well which
then gave me got me obsessed with you
know how do you do how do you get
control of that process how much did you
make from that and how was it nothing so
speaking of doing things for free I
wrote it for free yeah because I wanted
the experience I wanted to get to know
the producers and all that stuff so I
was like yeah sure uh no problems
whatsoever but walking away from that
realizing yo like it's one thing to work
really hard for free didn't care about
any of that but when it gets taken out
of your hands and why my estimation made
worse it just really made me want to
control that process that led me to
needing to get rich
I thought it would take 18 months it
took 15 years but it worked and so
that's how again in a very very brief
not sure explain how it worked what was
the business that you started 15 okay
are you able to disclose the numbers on
the film like how much I actually don't
know the how much it costs it was super
low budget so like a million dollars
something like that
um and how much I made I have no idea
literally none so by that point I was
crying let me ask what didn't you like
the most about the film uh so
storytelling is meant to elicit an
emotion if you fail to elicit the right
emotion from the audience at the right
time you have failed the movie did not
elicit the right emotion at the right
time for
um and no I don't want to paint like my
screenplay was Shakespeare was not the
screenplay was probably meh at best uh
but the movie didn't make it to Matt so
uh that discrepancy was frustrating so
when you're writing the screenplay you
know what you want the audience to feel
at this moment and because I'm actually
more of a director than just a writer so
I knew how this was meant to be shot
like what where you need to put the
camera what you need to get from the
actors all that and so I was on set
every day and it just wasn't
so got it tell us about that business
that you started what inspired it why
that I was a tag along so it was created
by these two very successful
entrepreneurs and it was a technology
company called awareness Tech and they
knew me from uh as a filmmaker and so
they'd seen me speak on film and they
were like hey we need a copywriter why
don't you come and help us but don't
think of yourself as an employee think
of yourself as a potential partner and
if you work hard enough and perform at a
high enough level will actually make you
a partner and they said that to
everybody and so I watched them make
that pitch to 30 40 50 people I don't
know it was just constantly and that's
how they would try to attract talent but
I took them seriously and I worked like
a fiend I didn't ask for a raise for
five years because all I wanted was
equity and so in the end I got equity in
the business but by the end I was so
burnt out and so unhappy because I was
chasing money that I went in and quit
and I was like here's your Equity back
knocking across the Finish Line can't
keep doing this at that point the equity
is worth about two million dollars and
I'm like uh this is just how many
miserable longer would you have had to
go to actually realize that Equity it
never would have gotten there I know now
looking back on it so at that time I was
just like good choice it would have been
a good choice if I'd done that at 18
months but I kept telling my wife no no
just another 18 months another 18 months
another 18 months and it's six and a
half years she said you're now damaging
our marriage because I would come home
and say don't even ask me about my day
and I don't want to talk about it and
when I would drive in because this was
in the Marina Marina Del Rey for anybody
familiar with SoCal and it's one of the
most beautiful places on Earth when I
would drive in it was like dark clouds
would roll in thunder and lightning I
was just so profoundly unhappy what do
you hate about it
um I hated that I didn't care about the
product I hated that
um I was in a very
aggressive environment events where
people were outright cruel now I will
say it worked perfectly for me and it
turned me into the person that I am now
so I'm actually grateful for it but when
you're doing all of that and you're
suffering every day for something you
don't believe in just trying to chase
money and the act of it is absolutely
hateful it becomes very hard to get
motivated to keep going in and so I
needed to wall myself off so I'd wall
myself off but that meant that my wife
couldn't ask me about it and so then
that started to make her feel like she
was sort of orbiting my life but not
actually a part of it and so when she
said look it's damaging the marriage and
for me my marriage is my highest
priority so I was like cool then
something has to change and so we had a
whole plan it's gonna we were gonna move
to Greece cut our expenses down to
nothing I was gonna go in and quit give
the equity back and I'm just going to go
write the Next Great American screenplay
come back get it made and I go in and
quit and give the equity back and I'm
driving home and my partners call me on
the phone like whoa you caught us off
guard come out to dinner with us go out
to dinner with them they're like we
actually feel the same what would it
take for us all to keep working together
so we laid out what that would look like
and that thing ended up being Quest
Nutrition
whoa Jack how did we end up back at the
studio this is so weird I have no idea
Graham I have a feeling it's because we
got to talk about Aura I don't really
wear a lot of rings here but you know
what you convinced me to try it out and
I gotta say I like it a lot I check it
every single morning I check my sleep
and it's one of the things I didn't
realize just how bad of a sleeper I was
you're a bad sleeper
careful it's really it's really bad and
it started tracking every single night
of sleep with the aura ring and it's
been incredible I never thought that I
would be uh opening an app this much but
every single morning it's not the first
thing I check it's cool because all that
data that you get from the app you can
actually use it to improve your sleep so
for example for me I noticed my sleeping
was way more efficient when I wear
earplugs and I saw data in the app that
shows that yeah so now I wear earplugs
like every night I also like how it
stays charged for up to a few days so I
don't have to think about like charging
it every single day it becomes annoying
but I could charge it once it's good for
a few days I don't have to think about
it I really like it a lot I didn't think
I would like it as much as I did it's
like that Health app on your phone but
like way way better it's like you take
that times a hundred and you get one of
these things so if you guys want to
check them out too it would help out the
channel tremendous we got an affiliate
link Down Below in the description uh
try it out let us know what you think
what's not to like and I'm not a ring
for it I don't like wearing rings but I
put this on with that said all right
guys let's get back to the podcast now
the irony of ironies is one of the the
promises that the three of us made to
each other was that we will never again
chase money and so once we stop chasing
money we made just all the money in the
world it's crazy and so it's one of
those like just ridiculous cliches how
do you go from Tech to Quest Nutrition
how did everybody thought we were crazy
because we were going at the time where
it was like that's how you make your
money this is like the height of this
would have been 2009 so 2009 everybody
in Tech it's like popping off we've
recovered from the.com bubble like this
is where you know Facebook is blowing up
there's just so much money everyone's
like you're gonna get out of that into
manufacturing what are you doing but we
had said it's got to be something that
we're passionate about it has to be
something that I know I'll fight for at
2 A.M on a Friday night that I have a
reason to be there other than money and
so I'd grown up in a morbidly obese
family so for me and it was different
for all three of us but for me it was
about fighting for my mom and my sister
and I was like I want to make food that
they can choose based on taste and it
happens to be good for them and so at 2
am on a Friday which I always use that
because I was real I remember one time
literally being under a wrapping machine
with bloody knuckles trying to repair it
because if we don't finish this batch if
the the protein matrix gets cold you
lose it and so every batch was worth
five thousand dollars and we just
couldn't afford it and so I was like
we're staying here till this gets done I
could spend 20 minutes just describing
that moment it's crazy but anyway that
at that moment when I asked myself why
am I doing this that I would have a very
profound and compelling answer and so
when I could think about my mom and my
sister I'm like yo you're going to do
this my sister ends up losing like 120
pounds it was incredible so it was
awesome and I had the emotional reason
to keep fighting
but because it was really coming from
that place and we look we were very
business savvy they had been in business
even longer than me by that time I had
been in business for almost a decade it
was like we had a lot of learnings under
our belt three Ultra Hardcore people
that have been working together for a
long time very disciplined but you put
all that together and I understood
social media before virtually anybody
else my partner understood the nutrition
just freakishly well and then my third
partner or sorry my second partner the
third of us was a literal Iowa farm boy
and so he knew how to build things and
so he was like when everybody told us
that you were never going to be able to
manufacture this kind of bar he actually
re-engineered equipment so that we could
it was just nuts man it seems like all
the right things at the exact level but
how do you go and start like I see the
see the why like here's why I'm gonna do
this but how do you even start doing
something like that and like coming up
with that concept of this is what we're
going to have this is what we're gonna
offer like is it a super concrete answer
for you so of everything you need to
start with a really Crystal Clear goal
okay so we want to end metabolic disease
okay big mission but what your goal is
not clear enough until you know what to
do with the next 15 minutes of your life
that's how I look at everything
all right so my goal is to end metabolic
disease what's stage one don't try to
change Behavior try to leverage it okay
word so I know people will eat junk food
okay so what if we could make junk food
that leveraged all of the junk food
science but did it with ingredients that
are actually good for you instead of bad
for you cool so we're going to need to
understand the biomedical markers that
we're going to look for like right now
I'm wearing a glucose patch we used to
check our blood and we would eat the our
own product to see is it working is it
not working because we had a belief and
I still believe it to this day the
number one thing you should pay
attention to is what is your glucose
levels if your glucose levels are
constantly high you're a diabetic so
it's like and we know chronic
inflammation all that stems from that so
we just started working backwards on the
problem but you have to have these
principles that's why when you and I
were talking in your interview I'm
always trying to distill what's the
principle so I can abstract it from that
moment and apply it to anything so all
right this is going to be a nutrition
company cool what are we trying to do
and metabolic disease why because my mom
and my sister are struggling from this I
don't want to die any sooner than they
have to so it's deeply personal for me
what are the things that have gotten
them there they're choosing food based
on taste could we get people to choose
food based on taste and move them
forward metabolically yes we can what
are form factors people are already used
to a protein bar why hasn't anybody made
this protein bar before as we found out
it's because all of the the scaled up
equipment had been engineered over seven
years with the use of high fructose corn
syrup once you take the high fructose
corn syrup out because it will elevate
your blood sugar which defeats our whole
purpose once you take that out it won't
run through the equipment anymore so now
you have to be willing to become your
own engineers and you have to develop
your own equipment it's crazy and so at
that moment where I'm sure a thousand
other people had the same mission one
did the same things with the same
beautiful reason all that but they got
to the point where they had to engineer
their own equipment they're like yeah I
know
we had an Iowa farm boy or they knew
what to do they were willing to do it
but they couldn't get the word out to
anybody else because they didn't
understand what I understood which was
that social media wasn't even called
that back then but it was going to
change everything and that I just wanted
to build community and I wanted I didn't
know the word authentic back then in the
way that we use it now but that was my
whole thing I was like guys I don't want
to be a slick marketer I want to be who
I am kept saying that I want to be who I
really am and so it was just like all
the things that are cliche now at the
time nobody was doing and my background
was filmmaking so I knew how to make
content so now you've got a guy who
wants to be authentic who's trying to
end metabolic disease so our product is
real leveraging this thing we now call
social media and knows how to create
content so it was just like all the
dominoes fell just two years before they
fell for anybody else and so we were
what was the startup cost how did you
fund that so that we did very little so
we got profitable off of ten thousand
dollars so from the software company so
we didn't burn the ships to the shore we
kept running the software company by day
and making the protein bars at night so
we were doing that until the company was
profitable and then I was the first one
to move over full time and then my
partners stayed there kept their
salaries I dropped mine to next to
nothing and then started running Quest
and then his quest started making more
money I could start drawing more salary
and just did it that way and then
finally to scale up we had to take a big
risk we sold the
um we sold awareness stack and then
reinvested basically most of that money
into buying the equipment because it
didn't sell for that much into buying
the equipment to fund Quest and so
that's how we were able to do it people
like working the two jobs and then also
balancing a relationship a she or wife
back then yeah she was yeah so what was
that 20 years
uh it was awesome so my wife just to be
a good wife when I was like hey we need
somebody to help us ship the product can
you just out of the living room just you
know ship one or two orders a day yeah
of course whatever you need it's all
good and then one or two orders a day
became one or two an hour or became one
or two a second and she just grew with
us until we were doing 80 million
dollars in revenue and then she was
finally like I hate this so much this is
not what I want to do with my life she's
also a filmmaker so we moved her over
into running the media Division and then
she was the one that kicked off what has
now become impact Theory which at the
time was called inside Quest and so it
was great so our lives were coming
together she was no longer orbiting
around me found her own entrepreneurial
chops really I mean she was one of the
founding team members who was there from
day one helped build that and then by
the time that we exited Quest she was
like a full-blown entrepreneur at that
point so it was her and I that started
this with a small team of Believers and
here we are got it and how much time did
it take and how much did it cost to go
from an idea to an actual tangible
product at Quest yes uh so it took us 18
months to come up with a formulation
that would have cost if we got
profitable off of 10 grand you probably
dropped on a two or three grand into the
formulation that would have been our
biggest single car last and then it's
just ingredients and stuff beyond that
but it took a long time I did not think
it would take that long what's crazy is
you know what your enemy is in food
it's water
I never would have guessed that now to
anybody that knows about food
the mold is gonna at least uh something
you need to be shelf stable yeah and so
we didn't to give you an idea of how
green we were we didn't even know that
it was water that would cause it to mold
and we actually considered a marketing
campaign of the first bar that rots to
let people know because this is before
like organic was like a big thing we
wanted people to know this is like
natural like it's not full of
preservatives and then we realize that's
a terrible marketing message let's not
do that let's find a way one week yeah
which is sadly true uh so we had to
learn things like how you bind water and
all that stuff and so we finally got to
a formulation that was shelf stable and
then we were Off to the Races so it was
18 months all the while you were still
doing the copywriting stuff at the tech
company as well by then I was doing way
more than that at that point by the end
of my tenure there I was the chief
marketing officer got it okay and then
you said it was a few thousand dollars
all the way until having the actual
tangible product yeah so it took us 10
grand to get profitable so with that was
all the early development getting a food
scientist to help us get the actual
formulation to buy the first really
small batches of ingredients all that so
there's not much this is why I freak out
and people are like oh you can't like
start because you have to have a ton of
money it's not true I mean look ten
thousand dollars nothing just needs that
it is a lot I get that I'm not saying
that it is easy right but I'm just
saying it's not the insurmountable thing
that people think it is and then what
about marketing to get your first ever
customers were you selling just like
family and friends or did you go to not
give them away so you want to find out
who's your ideal customer and we were
really focused on I want my customer to
be a walking billboard for the efficacy
of the product so we went to
bodybuilders now that was never going to
be the only person that buys your
product not if you want to scale you're
going to go out to the my mom and my
sister somebody that aspires to be in
great shape and so we went I'll tell
those people and said this is the first
protein bar that isn't a candy bar in
Disguise this is real so eat it test
your blood look at your results like
don't take our word for it actually try
it and they were like no way no way I'm
not eating it and so we would stand at
events like the Arnold or the Olympia
Carnival barking free protein bars the
first bar is not jumping Skies no one
would touch it so it's like just getting
that one or two people and so they would
try it the first day finally
begrudgingly walking around the show
they're starving it's in their bag
they're like all right I'll try this
they eat it they come back the next day
like
that's so good there's no way that this
doesn't have sugar in it like we're used
to people scamming in line we're like
dude test your blood sugar look at it
look at the ingredients try it and so it
just spread like wildfire people are
like oh my God this is actually real we
had dietitians using it in people's
contest prep it's crazy so now at every
pool party around America somebody would
you know walk up to the guy with
six-pack and say what do you eat you'd
be like Quest and so it's just like the
most organic stuff so we started doing
what we call mirror marketing which was
hey everybody we want to see what are
you cooking because people would use
Quest product to cook to make crazy
desserts how are you cooking with it uh
show us your physical transformation and
then we would just repost all their
stuff and so then they wanted to point
people to be like yo look at my recipe
or look at my transformation this is
just it was insane and did you guys have
a big marketing budget or was it mostly
just Word of Mouth like the product was
so good like testing right like they
don't have to have a marketing but their
stuff just sells itself and people
market for them yes and you need like
Twitter or sorry uh Tesla has Elon on
Twitter right where he's got a gazillion
followers and he knows how to get that
message out and to Rally the community
we had Facebook Instagram before
companies were using it so we were
showing that a brand could be effective
on there by building communities
celebrating your community getting them
to talk about it making them the cool
person that knows that Indie band before
anybody else and like that was all of
our credibility in the beginning and
then we made a really smart decision
that at first everybody thought was
crazy uh I I literally had to stand in a
room and everyone in the company took
turns point this is literal took turns
pointing at me and saying Tom you're
just being an [ __ ] and the whole
thing was I said we should go online
first rather than go in stores and so in
the end anyway despite all of that I win
the argument and everybody we try it and
that becomes the reason that we able to
keep High margins because we kept saying
no to retailers for a year or more we're
not going to go into retail yet and so
many people were walking into a GNC or a
vitamin shop saying why don't you carry
Quest that we were finally able to
negotiate terms that gave us enough
margin to really scale the business how
does that work to go into retail like
how do you get shelf space like that and
what are the terms like for the very
beginning because it sounds like you
were able to show the demand and then
leverage that to a better deal how does
that deal work 100 that's just like how
much they pay you to well so you you
have to build in all the different
channels that you're going to be selling
through so if you have a distributor
they're going to want 50 right off the
bat just plain and simple but they may
be selling to a retailer like Walmart
that's going to want 50 60 percent right
off the bat so it's like how do you deal
with both of those well you probably
don't because your margins are going to
go to virtually nothing if you have to
sell to a distributor that wants 50
points and they're going to sell to and
this is off retail and they're going to
sell to
um Walmart that's going to want their 50
point it's like what do you do so you
try like we did and not use a
distributor to get into key retailers
like that but that means you have to
build out your own sales for us so
anyway you break your channels down it
took me a long time to even understand
what a channel is I don't know if you
want me to go into that but it's
basically groupings of
points of distribution so gyms is a
channel big box retailers like Walmart
is a channel okay so you pick your
channels you pick your go to market
strategy with those channels and then
you have to negotiate all of your deals
by channels in some cases by retailer so
typically you're only going to have one
distributor in a channel you can get
multiple but it can get weird they're
all jockeying for a position and they
can battle against each other and you
have to deal with all that
anyway this I don't know how much of a
Treatise you want on that you can keep
pushing hard on that but anyway so you
figure out what's standard and then how
much can you deviate from standard based
on your points of Leverage we were
holding back we had huge demand in the
different channels of wanted to use us
and so we were able to negotiate better
deals so that we weren't giving out 50
points that we were able to keep a
richer cut in the beginning and that
helped uh
I'm just curious like as a small like
Grassroots Grassroots company how are
you able to compete with these other
massive billion dollar companies that
are offering protein bars as well and
were you nervous they would just do
exactly what you were doing what did you
do with that machine that you guys
created did you patent it or something
you can't patent a recipe so no we did
file for some patents on some of our
equipment some of the other things we
were doing though we thought we were
better off not filing for a patents you
have to reveal how you're doing
everything so better we thought to leave
it as a trade secret so some things we
just didn't do we actually Incorporated
corporate Espionage where our
competitors would send people to get a
job at Quest so they could see how it
was done and take it back so you only
have say an 18 to 24 month lead when you
get that big because we we were a rocket
ship in five years
we went from not existing to being
valued at over a billion dollars crazy
town so people are going to wake up and
be like all right you just ate all my
market share I have to figure out what
the hell you're doing uh so
what was the other part of that question
how do you do it yeah like especially in
the beginning right like how are you
able to compete with these massive okay
so the I live by a mantra there's always
room for the best
so we were in a declining category so
when we first launched in 2010 the
category had been declining for years
and more entrants were coming in by the
day and so when we originally pitched
the quest bar we had a distributor say I
need another protein bar like I need
another hole in the head and so he
passed now you can imagine as we became
like the thing he was not happy with his
decision to have passed
um and if you have something that is
actually better than the competition and
you Market it better and you make the
brand stand for something more there's
always a way to come from whatever
deficit you have to be Savvy there's no
doubt you have to be able to make noise
and get people to pay attention but if
the product actually does what you say
and you know how to articulate what you
do well
there's always a shot I'm sure a lot of
people always think like some of the
challenges in growing a company like
that would be finding Distributors
getting the supplies necessary and all
the legal stuff for you what did you and
the other partners obviously find to be
the most uniquely challenging barriers
that you guys had to manufacture make
through all day that that was the only
time where I was like oh are we actually
going to be able to pull this off
because we got told by people that have
been in the industry 30 40 years this
bar cannot be made and so we went around
the world China all across the U.S
Canada looking for equipment that would
make our very peculiar what we call
Matrix and
we would stop their equipment we'd just
seize it up and we started to think
maybe this really won't work
and my partner was like no I think I
know what to do but you're gonna have to
let me cut apart this equipment that we
spent all of our money on and if it
doesn't work now we're screwed because
we can't even sell back the equipment
because at least if we don't cut it up
we still sell it right right we'll have
failed but we can sell it back and so
it's like Do or Die mowing we're like
yeah let's do it and did and it worked
and and that gave us that first and look
we ended up making far fancier equipment
down the road once we understood why we
had gotten into work then we could go to
the other manufacturers and say we
basically need you to make us you know a
piece of equipment like this with these
tolerances and all that stuff and it was
funny because you'd walk around our
facility and it's like oh yeah that one
piece of equipment I could have bought a
Ferrari like a really nice Ferrari and
here I have this thing that slabs
protein bars but it worked out in the
end now what was your decision to sell
what was that like yeah so we ended up
being so successful that we now had
options we stopped agreeing on how to
run the company and what the future was
but we didn't need to agree anymore and
for me I was always doing this to to
control the art so that I could by that
point I thought of it as building a
studio and they knew that and so I was
like you know I think this is that time
what we've done is incredible we could
sell the company for a billion dollars
and let's do it and so I at that point I
do not speak for them I can't tell you
what was inside their heart and soul but
it was a an amazing 14-year Journey as
partners that had run its course and
gave me and Lisa a chance to spin out
the the
media side of quest which was pretty
weird to have a media company inside of
a protein bar company to spin that out
into a standalone company and part of
the um what I saw as the future that we
couldn't all agree on because I was like
brands have to step forward and say what
their values are you need to be able to
see the person uh create content around
who you are as a company what you stand
for all of that and so I had originally
started impact Theory back there called
inside Quest but basically the same show
and
um I was like this is really the future
that content is going to be such an
important part of what brands do and so
when we were like you know I don't think
it didn't match their vision for what
they wanted to do I just said cool let
me spin it out do a standalone company
and uh We're Off to the Races what did
they want at the time was it to try new
products and just go heavier into the
marketing side or it would be it would
be very unfair for me to try to
characterize
what they wanted to do but I will say
that it didn't involve media in the way
that I saw it and so I really thought we
need to and look it sounds
counterintuitive I totally get it we we
need to invest more money in the media
we need to be doing
more strange things in our marketing to
get a broader audience I wanted broader
appeal I wanted people using it as a
transformation tool I wanted to create
documentaries around the Transformations
and sponsor athletes that were you know
doing crazy things and so how much of
that they liked didn't like don't know I
will say on balance it was definitely
not a fit I felt very strongly in One
Direction they felt very strongly in the
opposite direction and it was like okay
do we battle this out does one of us
compromise in in a pretty big way or do
we just say this has been amazing and
part ways now when it's amicable and
go each do our own thing how does a
buyout even work at that point is it is
does a larger company just absorb
everything is it just your share that
gets purchased like how what's the
process like so what what ended up
happening was we said okay this is the
value that I brought to the company you
freeze that in time and say cool if this
whatever anything that you get over
where I'm at that's yours I'm not there
to build it that seems very fair to me
as it turned out we sold basically at
that same value so it didn't end up
mattering they didn't stay too much
longer after I left
um and but that was the deal if they had
taken it for the next 15 20 years and
built it you know into a three trillion
dollar business or something that would
have been all theirs
um
but yeah can you share what your
take-home was after selling in terms of
how much I walked away with raw dollars
I will say that it's
it was nine figures
get into math okay
it was in the nine figures somewhere it
was in the nine figures yeah and and I'm
just so curious because it is so such a
stupid question but you sell a company
for a billion dollars do you just get
like a check or like a deposit they
literally just deposit it in your bank
account you're kidding it's surreal what
what bank account did you have uh this
would have been at Chase this is just a
Chase account with nine figures in it
yeah and then and what about taxes uh
you pay them you pay them I've paid a
very painful amount of tax for living in
La we were talking about why I'm trying
to sell my house because I just don't
think the way California is going with
tax makes any sense uh so yeah but I I'm
I'm a big hey I love America I'm here to
pay my taxes so I have paid tax and I'm
not I'm not Savvy like you man I don't
try to be clever like but no [ __ ] pay
taxes what was it like though looking at
your bank account seeing nine figures
that's crazy what was the most amount of
money you had in your bank prior to that
point uh by that point I was I was
making a pretty good salary and have
been for a few years so
low six figures
low six so like a couple hundred
thousand yeah yeah to 100 plus yeah oh
people don't understand I was worth over
a hundred million dollars probably over
200 million dollars and I was driving a
beat up Ford Focus with a leaky exhaust
and was borrowing rides off of my
employees when my wife needed the car it
was hilarious what was your rent or
mortgage at the time were you just
Frugal in every facet of Life yeah so we
we had really we had a uh it was a nice
enough house don't get me wrong for that
period of my life I was very excited so
nobody while there were times in my life
where I was in a very small apartment by
the time Quest is thriving we're in a
nice you know middle class house and
um we had to put it up as collateral so
it was at risk but we had a decent house
but we stopped going out we sold because
it obviously we had two cars but when we
started Quest we had to sell it so that
we could cut our expenses back to
nothing so I went from making like 150k
down to making 50k and with the house on
the line and all that stuff and yeah we
just scrimped and scraped and our
mortgage was manageable and quite
frankly I rolled the dice a bit and it
paid off looking back now I wouldn't
because I had an adjustable rate
mortgage and had Quest not been
successful I would have gotten oh
Blitzer rated uh so got a little bit
lucky with that
um and yeah and being worth so much why
were you Frugal is it just rooted in
your DNA you don't have expenses I was
uh I we're in this house so like to say
they don't have expensive tastes me a
bit stupid but I only have expensive
taste for a house I don't the house is a
piece of art that you can live in so
I've always had a thing like I got
hardwired for houses being a
representation of wealth and my whole
life as a kid I want to be rich because
I was again I wasn't poor now that I
understand what real poverty is but I
thought of myself as poor so the whole
time growing up couldn't have all the
things that I wanted I've been working
full-time summer jobs since I was 12 to
get a Nintendo I had to work in a door
Factory nobody should cry for me but
like as a 12 year old you feel a bit
hard done by so I'm like yo when I get
older I am going to get rich and so my
every time I visualize that it was the
big house and all that and then once I
got the big houses like I don't need
fancy things so I the average thing that
I buy is manga so it's like nine dollars
so that's it I don't wear fancy most
some of my clothes I guess that I bought
a few years ago I went through a fancy
phase but almost all my clothes are
bought on Amazon your pants look
expensive they're not did I bought these
on Amazon for like forty dollars did you
buy that yourself yeah yeah yeah so I I
have a particular style that I like in
fact I am wearing the culmination of
what I was going to say so my pants I
bought on Amazon for forty dollars and
my shirt though I bought on in Tokyo so
I'm a psychopath for Tokyo techware so
as often as I can I will go to Tokyo and
Shop in their districts and so I'm an
anime junkie and so this was like a
collaboration of like this little
Boutique shop in uh Tokyo that did this
mashup with my favorite anime which is
Neon Genesis Evangelion so anyway so
yeah I don't have super expensive taste
beyond the house but the house is so
ridiculous that it feels absurd to say
that I don't understand would it have
deterred you from buying that shirt if
it if it was five times they cost or no
no no no because I mean look I have a
limit got it just so for instance I
almost never fly private and everyone
thinks I'm out of my mind but every time
I think about flying private like to to
go International is like 100 to 150 000
one way
so I'm just like that's an employee for
a year and a good employee for a year I
don't care enough to fly private I'll
fly first class so that matters but the
gap between first class and private is
astronomical so I could afford it but I
never do it so there's just I think of
everything in terms of what I can do
with the money because I'm trying to
build a studio I'm trying to build the
next Disney so my ambition is still so
much bigger than my net worth no matter
how big your net worth is Hollywood
wipes out like Saudi princes right so
as much money as I have I don't have
Saudi Prince money so it's like I know
better I know what this game is like I
know how it's played I know how quick
you can lose hundreds of millions of
dollars so that's not my game so I'm
making sure that we can play the long
game here so when you got that nine
figures in your account what was going
through your mind at the time and how do
you divvy that up in terms of what
you're going to do with it to make it
last I I am not thoughtful like that I
have way too high risk tolerance so that
would be a great question for my wife so
I would legitimately bet everything on
building the next Disney and grind
myself down to no dollars left in my
bank account if that's how it came down
and would have no heartburn whatever I
wouldn't feel weird about it at all
because as I'm trying to get people to
understand the once you have the
knowledge you can remake the money so
there is no point in my life where I
will ever struggle to make two three
million dollars a year I could go to any
Fortune 500 company if I wasn't going to
start my own and say look this is what I
know this is what I've done I'll work
for free for three months by the end of
it they will pay and give Equity it just
so I have no fear I will forever live a
whatever lifestyle I want to live
so my thought is just
I need to protect my wife who does not
share my same like
I just want to build this next thing I
care deeply about that next thing my
wife very much feels she's willing to
take risk up to a point but she feels
like look we sacrificed for so many
years we finally made it and if we're
not Reckless we never have to worry
about money again even at a very high
lifestyle so
I'm yeah I think about her far more than
I think about myself but I we obviously
run things here based on a budget and so
I know if everything goes wrong how much
would I lose for the year how many years
could I afford to do that before because
I feel a tremendous responsibility to
the team yeah
how did you meet your wife right you
guys are asking like the greatest hits I
love these questions okay so
uh my wife and I are a metoo story so
get ready for your channel to be
canceled uh I was teaching my wife was
my student and uh school for adults I
want to be very clear about that uh I
was teaching filmmaking and she was 21
at the time and she saw me at my best
and it was amazing and we hit it off
right away and when I met her I had
recently learned how to be good with
women because I was terrible up until
that point and truly how do you learn oh
it's really simple you must be willing
to walk away and you must be worthy I
don't know your audience well enough I'm
going to give you the truth you can edit
it out if you say the truth here here is
the the reality think about just hold it
in your mind for a second what sex
really is okay the the messy reality of
what sex is you have to go from high my
name is to that to do that you must be
worthy of that now you might be able to
trick him into doing it once but I've
gotten my wife to do that for 22 years
you have to be worthy so one you have to
be worthy two you have to have
confidence meaning you recognize your
worth and because you recognize your
worth you're going to act completely as
you are who you are because it does not
make sense to get somebody into a
relationship that's not going to work so
broadcast who you are and be willing to
walk away so if you are worthy of
someone inviting you into their body and
that that is an amazing incredible
moment that you guys can share and it's
your real Partners in that act because
I'm very much not a like don't get with
somebody that you you can Dominate and
push around get with somebody who is
your equal
we can go into that as much as you want
I have very strong feelings
but you want to do that and you need to
understand that you have that worth that
you've done the work that you're good at
something that matters and then that you
don't need that person and that even if
you feel like you need that person and
they're the only one for you and all
that the second you act like that they
will become elusive you'll never get
them and
you can't tolerate
the friend zone or anything like that
like I'll give you an example I never
had to say this to my wife but if I had
thought I was sliding into the friend
zone I would just say like hey if I'm
not what you're looking for totally
respect that you are lovely and I wish
you the best in everything I'm not
interested in the friend zone all the
best to you and you know if I can be a
reference or whatever let me know uh but
this is where we part ways and at that
point and I'm very good at this I would
flip a switch in my mind and I would
never think about that person again you
just you how long did it take to develop
that sort of mindset though 23 years
really and what was there an event or an
inflection point where you're like oh
got it if you want to get good at
something find somebody who's already
good at that go to them and ask them
what do you do beg for the absolute
truth and then when they tell you
believe them I went to George
leonardopolis yeah George got laid left
right and Center
and I said George is he Greek he is
great okay is he like a famous guy or
something not at all now he's just Greek
man and uh they're natural
charismatic that is as George was very
charismatic and very good looking and
did he have an accent though he did not
I grew up in America so he didn't have
that going for him but very Charming and
I said George what's the secret because
I am terrible with women and he said oh
you just have to be a dick to them and I
wanted to bang my head on the table and
I was like
one I know him and he isn't a dick so
he's saying something and it's so cliche
so finally I was like I'm not going to
reject this because the guy I know that
is the way that I want to be with women
is telling me that that's a secret he's
telling me in sincerity he's wrong but
he's telling me sincerely so what does
he actually mean and then I realized oh
he's always himself and he's willing to
walk away
and I was like that's so interesting and
so he isn't like oh what do you want
what do you like which then just puts
you in this like you're there to to
placate them yeah like it just makes you
okay I'm just gonna say the real words
you you
in my estimation if you want to be good
with the typical female you need to be
self-assured confident strong
um very good at something that they care
about and you need to embody all of that
and then you need to be wildly
interested in who they are make them
feel better about themselves when
they're around you than when they're not
and them feel like whoa this person
really lifts me up but they're honest
and they tell me the truth and they
don't ever pull punches and if they say
something that I don't like I'm going to
let them know that I don't like that
very calmly but just hey I like this I
don't like that
and
I was shocked at how intoxicating the
woman who is now my wife and she will be
the first to tell you that it didn't
work only on her I had had a chance to
test this out before meeting her and
realized and it was night and day could
not get laid flip a switch
very successful with women and was I was
laughing I was like I can't believe this
is true and then flashing back on my
life there was this girl that I really
liked in high school and she used to
always say when we're not dating you're
super cool and the second we're dating
you're not yourself and I couldn't
understand what she meant and so then I
played it back and I was like oh my God
it's because I had fear of loss and so
when we weren't dating it in fear of
loss because we weren't together so just
who I am that would get her attracted we
would date and then because I liked her
so much I had fear of loss so I started
trying to act the way I thought she
wanted me to act then I'm not
interesting there's no sort of power in
that there's just someone supplicating
themselves to you it's just not
interesting it's interesting so by
flipping that switch everything in my
life changed now I've only told one
woman that I love her I've been in a
committed relationship for 22 years like
so if anybody thinks they hear me saying
I'm a lothario or a Playboy that's not
my life at all but I am telling you that
it is a game of psychology and if you
don't play it well you will lose and so
all the guys out there right now that
are losing it is 100 their fault it is
not Society it is nothing other than you
do not understand the psychology of the
person that you're sitting across from
that you're trying to effectively sell
yourself to and because I took the time
to actually figure out what that is the
complexities because right now you hear
red pill [ __ ] be dominant they're your
property
the really terrible advice find a
partner find somebody who can challenge
you but be yourself challenge them be
worthy be good push yourself every day
be aggressive be
um hardcore try to take up as much space
as you can try to mansplain anything
that you're passionate about like don't
be hesitant at all and then shut up and
make sure that you're giving them that
space and you're drawing that out of
them and you show how much you respect
them and how interested you are in them
and find somebody you actually care
about so that this isn't a game and then
then just be open and honest and it's
incredible my wife is my equal in every
conceivable way on balance but there are
things that I am way better than her at
and in those moments I lead
and there are things that she's way
better than me at and in those moments I
follow and because I can do both of
those but I am not at all afraid to take
the lead
then you get an interesting Dynamic how
has your Dynamic changed over 20 years
oh brother so when she became an
entrepreneur that was the rockiest
period in our life because she had been
a stay-at-home wife for eight years so I
had somebody that cooked for me clean
for me took care of our puppies laid my
clothes out literally my clothes would
be laying at the end of the bed so my
gym clothes will be set out my work
clothes will be set out I did not have
to think of anything she sorted it all
all of our personal things flights trips
family my mom was going to get a
birthday gift all it's just all sorted
out I have to think about anything and
then she started thinking hey maybe I
actually like this entrepreneur thing
and then it was like you know she was
stepping into a far more aggressive
personality type like really starting to
feel her own and getting involved in
areas of business that had been sort of
my domain and the space that made me
feel cool and
that was a hard thing to navigate and so
what I told her was you have to give me
the opportunity to mourn and so because
the relationship I thought we were going
to have where you were going to be my
wife we're gonna have kids you were
going to stay at home take care of the
kids that's gone I don't get that
anymore and that was the the thing that
we got married based around so let me
mourn that but I want you to be whoever
you want to be and it would violate my
value system if I respond to in any way
other than I want to help you become the
best version of yourself the way that
you define it and so we've got all kinds
of standard operating procedures Rules
of Engagement that it would take me a
long time but I'm happy to answer
anything on that about how we ended up
making that work
how we did a transition period where she
slowly over like a week or two weeks
weaned me off of okay I'm setting out
some of your clothes not all of them I'm
making some of your meals but not all of
them down to okay now you're
self-sufficient we divide you know the
different work that has to be done all
that stuff
um and it's absolutely incredible but
you then if you're doing things that are
overlapping you have to be very
thoughtful about who has more expertise
in one area over the other should always
listen to each other you should want
disconfirming evidence but if you can't
agree on something you have to have a
rule of Engagement around what are you
going to do when you can't agree so for
instance I am the right person between
the two of us to be the CEO she will be
the first to admit it so when we founded
the company I and my Act of making sure
that she feels what she needs to feel
which is that I believe she is my equal
and she is my partner and she is my
priority the lawyer said look you need
to split the company 51 49 we don't care
who has 50 51 percent who has 49 but to
avoid illegal nightmare you must do that
and Lisa was like Tom will take 51 and I
was like Over My Dead Body we are 50 50
equal Partners make the ultimate divorce
nightmare I have failed if I don't have
enough influence over her that I can
navigate this process and I'm so
confident that I want what's good for
her and will sacrifice half of my [ __ ]
to make sure that her life is good why
would I ever do that I also know who she
is barring head trauma she's never going
to ask for more than half of the
business I'm just utterly convinced of
that and so make that the nightmare but
wife of mine let's be very clear if we
ever Collide on an idea and you can't
convince me and I can't convince you
which we will both try very very hard
and we will respect each other and
really listen and really talk but if
after all of that we can't agree we will
go with my idea every single time are
you okay with that yes cool then we can
March forward
now if in that moment I had been like oh
well I think how do you feel like that's
never gonna work because the reality is
I'm not willing to do this if that isn't
true because I am the right person to
make those decisions so
you have to have the clarity of knowing
when you're the right person you have to
have the historical track record of oh I
follow you whenever you're the right
person I back off you know that in your
bones you know that I listen you know
that I'm not saying this from ego I'm
saying this from we recognize what each
other's skill sets are and that happens
to be mine so anyway getting to that
high level communication that's what
people have to be able to do and every
day pushing yourself to be a better
version of yourself like that [ __ ] is
hard but if you do that for 30 40 years
you can be in real beast mode but
growing together is the hard part
because things are going to change and
if you can't navigate those moments well
you're in trouble and you didn't ask
this but I have one more this is on my
mind no I'm so into this all right so
there's one more thing that people
really have to be thoughtful about there
is a reason that so many marriages break
up around the 25-year Mark I always
thought it was because they had kids and
that's when kids leave the house now I'm
sure that can be a big thing that breaks
up marriages for sure but my wife and I
don't have kids and we have found our
marriage isn't in danger but we found
this new thing that we're colliding over
that I'm like oh my God I see how this
plays out in a couple that doesn't have
the tools that we have what ends up
happening is over time so you should
marry somebody that has a different
world views than you you don't want
somebody that thinks the same as you you
want someone with the same values you do
not want somebody that thinks the same
so my wife and I come at things very
differently I see how things could work
she sees how things will break that has
made us an incredible pair
so we each have these World Views and
over time life kicks you in the face you
learn a lesson and your world view
refines and it gets more robust and more
robust but remember you each have
different World Views but they're
becoming more solidified over time so
now 25 years into your relationship
you've got dramatically Different World
Views and you know that your worldview
is right and so now you've got these two
World Views that start clashing all the
time and you can't break them out of it
I just tweeted out about this today you
have to be very careful you can't want
people to think the way you think
because otherwise your world view will
solidify and it will become a prison and
so what happens is life teaches you the
way you approach the world is right the
way you invest is right the way you run
your YouTube channel is right look at
all your success now imagine that going
for 25 years now you're just like I'm
right like I don't know what do you want
me to say like this works man all My
Success everything that we've done it's
right it's right it's right but you have
different World Views and you both
believe they're right so unless you are
hungry to find that area where oh okay I
can't argue from the place of I'm right
and you're wrong but we both have to
argue from the fact that I believe I'm
right I feel right
and getting my solution my way will
yield what I want and the same is true
for you so now we're colliding over
something where it's not that you're
wrong it
gets very complicated you can't even see
what I'm thinking and feeling you hear
all the words but you don't see the
world through my distorted mirror you
see the world do your distorted mirror
so I can't see what you're saying
because I don't see the world through
your distorted mirror so now you you
have to go okay we're both smart people
who love each other we're colliding we
each think the other person is crazy
which is why you're getting upset
because you think how can you live life
like that it's so ridiculous
so you're like okay at this moment I
have to say even though I really really
believe that you would be better off
doing things my way like I can steal man
your argument I can tell you what your
argument is this is not confusion
even though I can do that I think you're
crazy and I don't want to do it that way
you have to have a rule of Engagement
for how do we approach this problem and
this is where most people break because
in that moment you're going to have to
do something sub-optimally
and your marriage has to be the thing
you want to protect the most because
oftentimes my wife and I will collide or
something around the business so now she
could be [ __ ] with millions of
dollars and I have to be willing to lose
that money to protect my marriage
because I'm gonna have to compromise to
some point on certain things it gets
complicated because I know that first
thing I said if we disagree it's always
going to be my idea but hey you've got
to contextualize if you're beating
someone to death all the time all the
time all the time like you're just gonna
demotivate them so even though by
agreement I could it's not wise
and I want this to get too complicated
so you have to be willing to compromise
there may be real consequences to that
compromise and you have to want that
marriage their ability to have high
self-esteem and to feel loved and
appreciated and to feel like you're
equal
you've got to want that for them so
badly that you will compromise on some
of the things you want and they have to
be willing to do the same if you can do
all of that it's everything man because
there are going to be moments where I
would just tell you a person loving you
and going to bat for you and being there
for you in the ups and the downs and
helping you think through the hardest
problems and not judging you when they
see you at your worst that is so much
better than money there's nothing
nothing I've tried it all there's
nothing better than that at least if
you're hardwired like I am so my
understanding
is that for conflict resolution between
a married couple that's been going on
for a while the best thing is to
acknowledge and to be mindful that there
is a distorted window for yourself
there is no objective right and wrong
which we can get into I'm going to give
you a quick hypothesis I'm not sure I'm
right about the reason yet I know I'm
right about the the symptom I don't know
if I'm right about the cause there's a
guy named Donald Hoffman yeah who
believes that all of the world is
basically a computer interface and if
you think about reality as being the
electrical switches that are either on
or off that's the reality of a computer
that's the reality of sending an email
that's the reality of playing Grand
Theft Auto but you don't interface with
it like that you send an email by click
clacking on a keyboard to make little
words appear on the screen but what's
really happening is electrical circuits
going on and off really fast to process
zeros and ones okay that's too
complicated so his belief is that we
evolve to have this user interface and
now we're just dealing with the world
through the user interface if he's right
and it feels like even though it may not
be literally true the outcome makes that
feel like it's true then you know my
distorted mirror is really just my
version of that interface it's not it
doesn't represent what is real
objectively we're not at the laws of
physics level
so since I know that I'm not dealing
with the the on and off I'm just dealing
with an interpretation of it it becomes
much easier to have this conversation of
I just recognize that my worldview is an
abstraction
so everything I believe is not it's not
literal truth I'm just dealing in the
the realm of psychology what we call
symptoms of whatever the underlying
thing is that has helped me a lot to get
out of my own way to not be like well I
know I'm right that this really is a
black coffee mug where my wife's like
it's gray what are you talking about
it's blue it's like you start to realize
yeah that might actually be how it's
represented for you with your computer
interface or your distorted mirror to
stick with one metaphor and so that
becomes easier to to stop thinking I'm
right and therefore we need to do what I
say when did you start thinking that way
this is going to surprise you in terms
of the answer when I was 14 15
I really wanted to be good with girls
and I wasn't
and so that began a very long journey of
what is it that I have to learn to get
good that led me to reading Cosmo
magazine which led me to thinking about
women through a psychological lens and
then
my mother gave me the best piece of
advice your audience is going to be very
surprised by the term this interview is
taken my mom gave me the best piece of
advice around women that I've ever gone
to this day and she said women need to
trust you in order to have an orgasm and
I was like what I'm sorry like how old
are you uh probably 15 16 and so I was
just like ah
trust doesn't even enter into the
equation for me I don't even need
another name so that was so strange and
it just made me go whoa I'm I'm having
one Experience One frame of reference
over here but for somebody else it it is
such foreign territory that I have to
begin to understand what is true and so
that put me on this Quest that led me to
neuroplasticity the human ability to
improve all of this stuff ends up paying
dividends because for a long time I
didn't think I'd ever be successful I
didn't think I was smart enough I didn't
realize that you could get better I had
a fixed mindset all this stuff but so
all these little pieces start coming
together with the Dao de Jing long story
uh so I start cobbling this idea
together that you can step outside of
your frame of reference which I wouldn't
have known to call it that then and more
thought of it as different brains see
the world in different ways and if you
can understand how they see it then you
can find a way to translate well this is
how I feel but I need to translate it
into your language to make you feel what
I want you to feel so something my wife
and I talk a lot about it doesn't matter
what you say matters what the other
person understands so to get to that
then you have to go oh well the female
brain is very different from the male
brain I understand it's highly
controversial but I'll just tell you
real life's gonna slap you in the mouth
if you want to argue that point and so
by embracing that and so how do you
define truth it'll be an easy way truth
is
if I believe it and act as if it were
true does my prediction engine work or
break when I look at the world with the
assumption that the female brain is
different and very specific and
predictable ways I can predict the
outcome of my actions bouncing off my
wife just as an example
better than if I assume she views the
world in the same way that I do if I
group women into a rough group and I
make predictions about my behaviors and
the response I will get from them based
on putting them in a group and of course
huge distribution we have way more in
common than we have separate where
compared to other things we're basically
the same but if you have if you operate
with that you'll find that your
prediction engine is way better at
predicting outcomes and so the more you
get into steering your life by
I believe they're saying to be true any
it's a hypothesis scientific method
tells me any hypothesis makes a
prediction if that prediction holds true
then the hypothesis becomes a thesis so
I'm just constantly trying to get my
best guess which is my hypothesis tested
to see if the predictions it makes
actually are true and when they are then
I upgrade that thing to a thesis I never
say it's fact or it's true largely
because of the Donald Hoffman problem so
I'm constantly looking for that
disconfirming evidence that will give me
a better way to perceive what's
happening so my prediction engine will
be even better
and so you refine refine refine let's
say you're in a relationship with the
girl for a couple of years how do you
know that this is the one that you
should spend the rest of your life with
like what are the pillars to a
successful marriage I asked Alex and
Layla hormozy this question they gave me
a very similar answer to what I thought
the answer was and I want to know your
opinion yeah so what you're looking for
is
shared values
but complementary World Views so again
to give the example between Lisa and I
I'm uh move towards something Lisa's
largely move away I look and see
opportunity no matter what I'm very
um I don't mind risk at all and Lisa is
more risk-averse she sees how things
could break she's about systems and
process and so when you put us together
once we realized that we needed to Value
the tension between the two of us and
that it's what makes a kite work you
need a kite and a string if you have
just the kite the wind will blow it into
nothingness it will crash land in a tree
end up on the ground whatever if you
have just a string that lays on the
ground but you have a kite and a string
the dynamic tension between the two if
they both respect each other now it can
keep that kite Aloft so she's a string
I'm the kite neither of us are useful
without the other but we have core
values that are the same so for both of
us our marriage is our number one
priority we have certain views around
family communication uh what to pursue
not pursue so just a lot a lot of shared
values so look for that and then because
I am such a huge love junkie I think you
want to look for somebody that makes you
feel like there's no way that two people
have ever felt like this before at the
beginning you have to understand that
the neurochemistry that's going to
change over time but that moment of like
yo I'm so into this person because if
you're not into that person because it
will get hard and when you ask yourself
why am I with this person if you don't
know you're in trouble and then the last
thing I will say is I highly recommend
especially the men to do some sort of
ritualistic scarification
so it could be as simple as a tattoo
that's what I did but you wanna it only
worked for me because I it's the only
tattoo I have I'm not like a tattoo guy
if you're a tattoo guy it's not going to
work but you want to do something
permanent that will remind you you are a
different person before you get married
than after so immediately after getting
married I took a tattoo that I designed
and give to my wife as a wedding present
and got it tattooed and the whole time I
did it I wanted to focus on the pain
wanted to focus on the permanence and
that I was doing this specifically to be
a different person at the end of this
came from a book called The Power of
myth where he talks about one of the
reasons he thought that so many
marriages fell apart is there's no
meaningful ritual that demarcates single
life from married life and so then I did
a lot of things around really thinking
about my willingness to die for my wife
and all of that and so just spending an
inordinate amount of time thinking about
that my wife and I never even joke about
divorce we don't even say that word in
our house we call it the d word so there
is no exit it's there look there are
things neither of us would stay in an
abusive or Loveless marriage
um but it's our job to make sure that it
never gets there and may have a lot of
tools and tactics to make sure that we
don't get there but it should be the
most amazing thing in your life Barnum
oh
I would love to continue talking about
that but I definitely think we should
probably get back to the the sale of
quest because that's also I mean that's
why we're here to talk about your
fantastic Journey as an entrepreneur I
do want to say this I am a huge fan of
quest I got put on shout out to Eric
from try carrots do we have uh chips
here there are chips over there I
noticed I didn't want to open them
because you were shooting with him
before and I was like this is gonna be
the loudest thing if I open up this bag
of chips yeah I know but I gotta say
right now I'm on I'm on two packs a day
nice yeah I'm on two packs of quest
chips a day you know I can stop whatever
I want I swear I can but I love them
they taste so good they're really
healthy I put my housemates onto them
and uh lovely so let's let's talk about
after the sale so I'm just so curious
It's kind of it's kind of like winning
the lottery then again with a ton of
effort what did you do the day after the
sale were you just completely absolved
of all of your work that you had been
doing for Quest and you were just like
free to do whatever you'd like with your
time so we took money in two stages so
the first day age was we took a small
investment but at the price it was
absolutely massive so that was the like
clicking Refresh on my banking app
button like oh my God and now you know
we're worth so much money that was that
moment I ended up making even more money
the second time but by then it was like
I was already very wealthy and so it
didn't have the same I possessed but the
first time it was really important to me
that I was at work on time went in did
my thing no one at Quest knew when the
money hit because it was like I'm here
to build something I'm on a mission I'm
not worried about that then the second
time I had already been out of the
company for two years I think before
like the final sale sale sale finished
and then the second tranche of money hit
um so yeah by then I had I literally we
uh wrapped Quest on a Monday and started
impact theory on Tuesday so I didn't
take time off didn't take a vacation
like for me it it I stopped chasing
money eight and a half years into my
Journey so it was not about the money
work ethic means a lot I think that
people should steer in life by how you
feel about yourself when you're by
yourself and so when I was going to be
alone I knew I'd want to say the day the
money hit my account I worked just like
any other day and so yeah that you
didn't buy anything lavish so I did end
up buying something for my wife but I
didn't buy anything for myself what'd
you get her uh we got a cool piece of
jewelry which now I don't remember if it
was a bracelet or a necklace whatever
that wasn't super meaningful to me
um but and because she had worked so
hard it wasn't even like I was buying
her something it was like she had earned
that money too so like there was no sort
of cool romantic moment in that for me
um I think there was for her because
that was like her like I'm a bad [ __ ]
moment like I did this I can buy this
myself like I earned this and so that
was really cool for her and really meant
something for her
um but for me it was about I show up to
work in this same way despite having the
money and why do you do this podcast I'm
just curious because you I mean you have
a ton of money you made a ton of money
you don't necessarily need to be making
more money from this podcast I'm
assuming right I'm sure it's expensive
to keep this house going on and
everything but what is the purpose
behind this okay so that is a very
detailed answer so I'll give it to you
in a nutshell if you want to push in on
anything we can so first and foremost
you need to make a self-sustaining
economic engine so I'm trying to build
the next Disney I'm never just going to
be able to fund that forever right so
Disney's a behemoth billions of dollars
so I need to build a company that makes
money and the great news is I can sell
fund it for years and get it going and
getting off the ground to huge risk all
that because of the very fortunate
position that I'm in but ultimately
impact theory has to make money the
second reason was even before I left
Quest I knew that I have a magic trick
and that magic trick is I can explain
very complicated ideas and make them
accessible to people and I was like I'm
gonna go from being the protein bar guy
to to building a Hollywood studio no
one's going to take me seriously no one
even knows who I am so I'm just going to
be another Rich muck trying to make
movies I'm like that's not going to work
so my thesis was if you put me in front
of the camera I can go impact millions
of people's lives and so when I want to
sell something to Netflix I can say to
my community hey I'm going to be at
Netflix
pitching this idea and 5 000 people show
up in the parking lot and be like yo
I'll watch anything that impact Theory
makes and that would be huge and then my
second thing was some of the people in
that Community are also going to be
Executives at these Studios and they'll
let me come in and Pitch just because my
contact my content has impacted their
lives which has already happened and
we've had some really amazing
opportunities come from that and then
the third thing is that what we really
need is to find all the talented writers
directors and things that I just need to
broadcast be able to tell people what
we're up to so that they'll see that
they'll understand what we're all about
and they'll want to come be a part of
this and so
getting eyeballs and what you're doing
is really really really important the
only part of this that didn't work out
was I also thought that people would go
oh uh tell them I watch all your videos
are amazing the comic books you're doing
those are about empowerment too yeah I'm
gonna read Comics it doesn't work like
that you're either a comic reader or
you're not and you need to approach
people with Comics or TV shows whatever
in a totally separate way so we're
actually now bifurcating the company so
it'll be impact Theory and impact Theory
Studios they will have their own
identities they'll be philosophically
aligned but if you go to impact Theory
Studios it'd be like landing on Disney
you'd see characters
animation cartoons video games that
stuff and you wouldn't see the shows the
university all of that and then also the
only reason that I'm doing all of this
everybody needs meaning and purpose
that's critically important and I knew
that going and retiring and being a rich
guy on a beach somewhere was never going
to make me happy so I wanted to make
sure that I could show up and fight for
something every day and so what was
going to be that thing that I could
fight for and the app answer for me was
I took myself from scrounging my couch
cushions to find enough change to put
gas in my car it's a real story to
selling a company for a billion dollars
and I was like I'm not smarter than the
next person but I have built a frame of
reference that's more useful and so I
was like yo I can teach these ideas
so it actually started as Quest
University where I was just telling the
employees like hey I want you here
because you know that I believe more
about your future than your own mother
and so I'm going to teach you how to do
whatever you want teach you everything I
know about being an entrepreneur all
that so you can control your life
they're just ideas and you can adopt
them as readily as I did and so started
there and then we started this I was
like okay our meaning and purpose is to
make sure that nobody gets to the age of
15 without at least encountering a
growth mindset at scale through story
now that we're bifurcating the two
companies it'll basically be ideas what
people think of impact Theory now and
entertainment which is the comics and
video games and web3 nft stuff do you
think in order to build a 10-figure
company you have to be some sort of way
such as obsessive high IQ or as Jordan
Peterson would say not agreeable is
there some sort of like stereotype that
fits the type that can build a 10-figure
company yeah so I think you're going to
have to be all of those and get the
timing right so there is a level of
intellect that is going to be absolutely
critical to build a company of that
scale I think you can build a nice life
with a solid IQ so I don't want people
to overly focus on intelligence it's far
more about skills but I used to teach a
business class called business decision
making it's the only thing that matters
if somebody's teaching you copywriting
you're going to be made it best like
it's just what's it'll build you a
decent business and if you're okay with
a 10 million dollar business which I
would not be it's perfectly fine but if
you really want to build something you
have to find a problem that people have
you have to solve it with an incredible
product you have to be amazing at
managing people you have to be able to
paint a vision you have to be able to
make a product that's better than the
next you have to understand marketing
and storytelling psychology Finance like
it's it's really unbelievable and on top
of that you have to be so driven that
you can run what I call the physics of
progress so every business I don't care
what it is is just a string of trial and
error so physics of progress is just a
scientific method recontextualized for
business so you're going to come up with
a hypothesis
that's you and that's just your best
guess of all right I'm here I want to
get here and there's an obstacle between
me and my goal
my hypothesis is my best guess about
what I would need to do to overcome that
obstacle then you turn that into a thing
that you can do you do that thing it
will fail to some degree you have to
stare nakedly at your own inadequacies
figure out why it didn't work be very
honest about that which will then
re-inform your new hypothesis which is
better educated now you will come up
with a better thing to do you will try
that hopefully it will be more
successful but it'll still fail a bit
you will have to stare nakedly at your
own inadequacies figure out why it went
wrong and just keep doing that over and
over and over and I know that we're out
of time there are a million different
places that it breaks down but mostly
it's ego and skill set quick answer can
we get does being rich make you happy uh
being rich doesn't make you happy but it
is a profound facilitator I would rather
be
um happy and Rich than happy and not
rich right it probably gives you the
freedom that you know you a lot and if
you're like me and you're a builder it
really allows you to Short Circuit a lot
of the early pain and suffering and just
a random question because I always get
curious when I see places like this how
much does it cost to have this house
just like like exist property taxes the
Landscaping I mean you have a a literal
wall on the outside of this house that
is just like covered with a bunch of
plants and everything I'm sure all that
can be the water bill including tax and
all that stuff it's high six figures
High six figures just to have have this
house exist yeah can I take a guess at
it
600 can I take a guess yeah I was about
to say 650. right you're almost bang on
yeah daddy's crazy property tax alone is
about 475
000 a year maybe 500 Grand depending on
the assessment but it is
the city of Los Angeles and well it
becomes difficult now to deduct that
because of the uh the salt cap 10 grand
oh wow
yeah how's the Uber looking uh three
minutes oh yeah you're right you're just
right on Sunset random questions Graham
um anything you want to pitch or
anything you want to go for where could
we I do want to say we would love to
have you back on the bus oh my God at
some point because I feel like we just
scratched the service we're at an hour
20 we have to go shoot something else
we're literally ubering right to the
next shoot I'd say if you guys want to
see a longer episode I could do this
easily for like yes three hours yeah
same same me on yours yeah yeah man I'm
all for it you should just make it a
whole day yeah anything we could ever do
for you less serious has been incredible
very kind guys thank you it was a lot of
fun thanks I love this thank you so much
my pleasure anything you want to pitch
or anything you want to at tomb bill you
come and find me there we go nice and
simple cool thank you so much thank you
guys for watching really appreciate it
until next time cool thank you man I
really want to go longer on this